Professor Robert
Shiller: Today I want to
talk about options.
I should just say what an
option is.
I'll write the word.
It's a contract that has an
owner and the owner of the
option contract has rights to
find in the contract either to
buy or sell some thing--let's
say a share of stock--at a
specified price and specified
date.
There are two kinds;
there's a put and a call.
A put option is the right to
sell.
It's typically a hundred
shares, so we'll say a hundred
shares of a company;
let's say it's Google.
The option would have--if it
was a put option and there was a
price, then you would have the
right up--let me see,
there's the exercise price,
also known as the strike,
and there's the exercise date.
I should also emphasize that
there are two kinds of options.
There are American,
so called, and European,
so called.
It has nothing to with whether
they are in America or Europe
because in Europe they trade
both American options and
European options and in America
they trade both American options
and European options;
so, it's very unfortunate
terminology.
The American--what this
means--an American option means
the right to exercise the option
on any date until and including
the exercise date;
with European,
it's only on exercise date.
That's what those words mean.
So, usually we're talking about
American options.
If you have an American
option--American put option--on
shares of some stock,
then you have the right anytime
you feel like it,
until the exercise date,
to sell that option at the
price specified in the contract,
called the exercise price.
If it's European,
you have to wait until the
exercise date and then you have
one day when you can do that.
A call option is the right to
buy a share of stock or whatever
it is--whatever is specified in
the option.
In a traditional option,
there are two parties;
there's the buy of the option
and usually we present them from
the perspective of the buyer of
the option.
The buyer of the option pays a
price to buy the option--not to
be confused with the exercise
price--and then,
depending on whether it's
American or European,
has until the exercise date to
exercise the option;
but, the buyer doesn't have to
do anything.
You can just do nothing;
you can buy the option and if
you do nothing it becomes
worthless because the only way
the option ever gives you value
after you buy it is if you
exercise it,
meaning you say,
I will use my right to buy or
sell.
The other party is the writer
of the option.
Because it's a contract,
it has to be between two
parties.
Somebody is on the other side
and you can do either one;
you can either buy or write an
option.
If you--let me make this clear;
if you write a call option,
then what you are committing
yourself to do as the
writer--you sign the contract
from the writer's contract,
which goes along with the
buyer's contract.
Well, it provides rights to the
buyer.
If you write a call option,
then you--and say it's
American--then you are signing a
contract --let's say it's on
stock--to deliver one hundred
shares to the other guy,
the buyer, whenever that guy
feels like it.
That guy will pay you the
contracted price,
so it's not--it doesn't seem
like much fun to be a writer of
an option because you
have--you're just sitting there
waiting for this other person to
make up his or her mind.
There's a benefit;
mainly, you get the money.
The buyer of the option pays
you up front for providing this
right to the buyer,
so writers of options write
them hoping that they expire
unexercised;
that's when they make money.
If you write an option and the
buyer of the option pays you the
money up front and then you
never hear from the buyer again,
then you're--that's the way you
like it.
So, you make money by writing
options and hoping that they
don't get exercised.
Of course, you can write a put
option and that means--if you
write a put option,
you are signing a contract that
says that whenever this other
guy on the other side,
the buyer, decides to,
that guy will sell you a
hundred shares at the specified
price.
Again, you're laying yourself
open to, whenever this guy wants
to, you've got to receive a
hundred shares and pay the
money.
Now, these kinds of contracts
are very old and,
in fact, we had a conference
over the weekend at the Yale
School of Management on--it was
a very interesting--I've never
experienced anything quite like
it.
Maybe I should put the website
up for you to look at.
There's a book;
it's called The Great Mirror
of Folly,
written in 1720 about the stock
market and the Beinecke Rare
Book Library has a copy of it.
They're very rare--about the
stock market crash of 1720.
Did you know that there was a
big stock market crash in the
year 1720?
What was happening in New Haven
in 1720?
Well, I know one thing that was
happening in 1720 in New
Haven--I'm guessing;
I'm pretty sure.
You had some pretty angry
investors who lost everything in
the stock market,
but it couldn't have been the
U.S.
stock market,
which wasn't created yet.
The crash of 1720 was primarily
in Paris and London,
also less so in Amsterdam;
those were the financial
centers of the world.
So, I'm speculating there must
have been someone here in New
Haven;
probably Yale University lost
in this crash--I don't know.
There must have been someone
here who lost--it was a huge and
devastating stock market.
This is the first one actually;
the first stock market crash.
We had a lot of fun at this
conference;
it just relates to options.
I'll tell you why it relates to
options, because people were
writing options galore in 1720
on stocks.
The book--if you search on
Great Mirror of Folly on
the Web, it'll come up with our
conference and proceedings.
Since this book--copyrights
expire after,
well, it's a complicated
formula, but in less then a
century.
So, this is all public domain,
so Yale has it up on the Web
and you can read the whole book.
Unfortunately,
it's written in Dutch,
which might deter some of you,
but it has lots of pictures.
We had great--at this
conference, the--it was the most
interdisciplinary conference
I've ever seen because we had
professors from the Art History,
Comparative Literature,
Finance, Economics,
and Psychology.
We had scholars from all over
the world who knew about the
year 1720, including a lot of
Dutchmen who were here.
Anyway, the highlight of it
was--one highlight for me was,
it had a--we saw a picture of
an option from this time--an
option contract to buy stocks
from Amsterdam.
It showed it was a printed form;
they had printed forms back
then, at least in Holland they
did.
So, a printer had printed up
with blanks to fill in.
There's a place to fill in the
exercise price and the exercise
date.
I don't know whether it was
American or European at the
time, but I'm sure if it was
American they didn't call it an
American option in 1720.
They didn't even call them
options.
Of course, it's all in Dutch,
so I don't know;
it was some other word--not
options.
I'm just saying this because
the-- The other interesting
thing about 1720 is that they
didn't make the same distinction
between investing and gambling
that we do now.
Right now, anyone on Wall
Street is very loathe to have
any suggestion of connection
with gambling,
but back then they didn't care.
So, lots of stocks would have
lotteries attached or there
would be all kinds of--something
called a tontine,
where a group of investors
would invest in something and
then all the money would go to
the last one to die,
after all of them died but one.
That's a sort of gambling;
I don't know what sense it
makes, but they did that.
I remember an old story on--I
just heard this somewhere--from
the 1920s.
Two brokers on the New York
Stock Exchange floor were
talking to each other and one of
them says, "I'll be you $5 that
the market's going to go up."
Then the senior man scolded him
and said, "are you betting?
You will be thrown off this
floor permanently if I hear that
word again."
So, that attitude has
persisted--that investing should
be distinguished from gambling.
I suppose there's good reason
for that because gambling
instincts can take hold of us
and investing has a good
purpose.
Unfortunately,
our emotions can carry us away
from the good purpose and
gambling is not investing.
Back in 1720,
the distinction was not so
clear and this event was so--it
got--the reason they called the
book The Great Mirror of
Folly is that the event got
totally crazy.
People were squandering their
life fortunes.
I'll tell you one more story.
We had a great time at this
conference because this book,
Mirror of Folly,
includes plays that were
written in 1720 and performed in
Amsterdam about the crash--about
the stock market crash.
The organizers of this
conference got some students
from Saybrook College to perform
one of the plays from Great
Mirror of Folly.
Is anyone here from Saybrook?
Okay, you weren't in the--I
didn't see you there though.
There was a scene in the play
where the young woman was being
told by her father that he
intends for her to marry a very
promising young man who is
speculating in stocks and will
soon be rich.
She is very skeptical about
being forced to marry;
she has somebody else in mind.
The father says that the other
young man is worthless;
he'll never amount to anything.
But, she stuck by her guns and
insisted that I will never marry
a man who's in love with the
stock market.
We don't know what happened
because it's all fictional,
but as we know,
the whole stock market crashed,
so she was right on two counts
probably.
Anyway, that's all
about--options are very old,
but they've emerged more
recently as very important
contracts.
In particular,
what they didn't have in
1720--in fact,
they didn't have anywhere until
recently--is an options
exchange.
The problem with a traditional
option is that it's a contract
between two parties.
If you write--if you buy an
option, you're at the mercy of
this other person.
So, if you buy an option that
was written by a broker,
as they were in 1720,
what if the other guy
doesn't--he just skips town;
he's gone.
You bought this option to
either buy or sell and then when
the date comes you can't find
this guy.
So, what do you do?
You obviously were cheated out
of your money.
So, we created--that was a
problem until 1973,
when the first options exchange
opened.
Well, I think there may have
been ways of dealing with the
problem, but not before '73.
But, this is the first options
exchange--Chicago Board Options
Exchange--which was a spin off
of the Chicago Board of Trade.
Now, what they did was they
organized a central marketplace
for standardized options.
Options used to be written for
whatever exercise date anybody
wanted;
there was no standardization.
An options exchange is like
creating a futures market when
you only had a forward market in
the past.
They started trading options on
U.S.
stocks in 1973 and they require
that the writer of a naked call
has to put up margin.
What is a naked call?
If you write a call,
you are standing ready to sell
a hundred shares to the buyer,
whenever that buyer decides--if
it's American--to do that.
But you're naked if you don't
own the hundred shares.
One way you can do it is,
you can show that you own a
hundred shares,
so there's no way that you
could fail to deliver.
If you're naked,
then you are required to put up
margin and the margin is an
amount that was enough so that
if you fail to deliver,
the CBOE could access your
margin account and buy the
shares on the market to sell to
the buyer;
there'd be enough money to do
that.
The margin requirement for the
writer makes the contract secure
so that there is really no
counterparty risk with options
purchased on an options
exchange.
Now, there are many options
exchanges, but the CBOE--I'm
just listing it--was the first.
Now, futures exchanges sell
options on futures;
that's the same thing as an
option on a stock,
but instead of a stock
contract, it's a futures
contract.
That would be done at the CME
Group, which is a futures
exchange.
That's just--we're just talking
about where you can do these
things.
Did I explain the concept of
options?
Maybe I should go through
the--I have here a plot
illustrating a call option.
On the vertical--on the
horizontal axis,
I have stock price;
that's $0 a share,
$5 a share, $10 a share.
I'm showing it up to $45 a
share.
Now, I'm going to illustrate
the intrinsic value of an option
with a $20 strike price.
Now, the option would be
typically for 100 shares,
but I'm going to describe it as
if it were an option to buy one
share;
so, it would be 1/100th of a
typical option.
This broken straight line is
what we call the intrinsic value
of the option,
which is the money you could
get if you exercised it right
now.
If you decided--we'll never
have intrinsic value negative
because you wouldn't exercise.
So, let me explain what this
means.
Suppose you own an option with
an exercise price of $20 and the
price of a share is $15.
What is the value of that
option today--the intrinsic
value?
Well, it's nothing because the
option gives me a right to buy a
share at $20,
but hey, I can buy it under the
stock market for $15,
so I would never exercise the
option today.
It would be worthless;
it would be worth minus $5 if I
exercised it today because I
would be paying $20 for
something I could get for $15,
but I'm not going to call it
minus 5;
I'm going to call it 0 because
you just--you won't exercise.
If the stock price is below the
exercised price,
I have a value.
On the vertical axis is the
intrinsic of the call;
I have to distinguish it
between actual value.
This isn't the price that is
quoted for the option;
this is what it would be worth
if you exercised it today if it
were--the option has value
beyond its intrinsic value
because even though it's
worthless today,
it might be worth something in
the future.
I'll come back to that but this
is just--I'm just talking about
intrinsic value.
Now, what if the stock price is
$30 today.
What is the value of the
option--the intrinsic value?
Well, it's going to be $10,
obviously, because if you
exercise it today,
you're buying the stock for $20
and you can sell it today for 30
on the stock market;
so, the difference is 10.
This line here--it doesn't look
like a--this is a 45º
angle here--doesn't look like
it, but that's what it is.
It has a slope of one.
It's very simple;
the intrinsic value for a call
is just a broken straight line;
it breaks at the exercised
price.
To give you a little bit more
jargon, in this region we say
the option is "out of the
money."
That means, exercised today,
it would be worthless.
This one right here is called
"at the money."
If the stock price is equal to
the exercised price,
then the stock--we'd call the
option at the money,
for a call.
Here, if the stock price is
above the exercise price,
we say it's "in the money."
This line goes off into
infinity;
I just stopped it there.
That's straightforward, right?
Anyway, this does illustrate
something about options that is
different from anything we've
discussed before.
This is a broken straight line,
not a straight line.
All of our talk about
portfolios to date has been
linear.
When you combine stocks,
you are making your portfolio
respond linearly to the return
of any one of the stocks in the
portfolio,
but this is non-linear because
we have a break;
that's what options do,
so it's non-linear finance.
Some people are confused about
what options really are.
Often people say,
well if I buy a stock option
that means I can make up my mind
later whether I want to buy and
sell.
So hey, I'm just getting the
right to be indecisive or
to--well, think of it this
way--I haven't made up my mind
whether I really want to invest
in options or not--in stocks or
not--so,
I'll buy an option and that
gives me the right to buy.
You could say that and a lot of
people think that way.
Like, a company will think,
we're trying to decide whether
we want to build this shopping
center.
So, we'll buy an option on the
land underlying where we would
build the shopping center and
we'll think more about it and
decide whether it's a good idea
to build a shopping center.
You could do that,
but there's something a little
bit misleading about that
reasoning because whether or not
you decide to build the shopping
center,
if you buy an option on the
land you will always exercise it
if it's in the money on the
exercise date--whether you build
a shopping center or not.
Suppose you couldn't decide
whether to build a shopping
center and you bought an option
on land and then someone comes
in and says,
well we have to make up our
mind today;
the option is exercising--is
expiring--if we don't exercise
it today it's worthless.
What do you discuss at your
meeting?
You don't discuss whether we're
going to build the shopping
center or not;
that's irrelevant.
You discuss,
what can we sell the land for
and if we can sell it for more
than the exercise price,
we will always exercise it.
So, there's no--the assumption
in finance is that all options
that are in the money on the
exercise date are exercised and
there's no choice.
The word option might be
misleading because--you could
choose to be dumb and not
exercise it, but that's not what
it's about.
On the other hand,
options really are central to
our thinking about a lot of
things.
I'll give you an example of an
option that you might not
consider an option.
This is the option to marry
somebody.
Sometimes people will complain
that their boyfriend or
girlfriend cannot commit.
We've been going out for three
years;
it's time that we get married,
but this person--the
counterparty--cannot seem to
decide.
Actually, one view of it--of
that situation--could be that
this person is just better
schooled in finance than the
other because one principle of
finance is that you should never
exercise an American call early.
I'm not this cynical about
relationships;
I'm just telling you a story
that comes to mind.
You'd never want to--I'll come
back to that--you never want to
exercise an American call early,
so that's why there isn't an
important distinction between
European and American.
Just in the case of
relationships,
suppose your girlfriend or
boyfriend really wants to marry
you and is still giving you
time,
then you instinctively know you
should wait as long--I'm saying
not really,
but I'm saying in terms of
theory;
you should wait until the last
day when this other person says
it's now or never because
there's always exercise--there's
always option value.
There's always a chance--maybe
that will become clearer.
I don't know if you like my
analogy.
I'm not cynical about these
things as some people are.
Peter?
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Robert
Shiller: This is a call
option up here,
but--this is a call.
I'm going to show you a put--go
ahead.
What arbitrage--
Student: [inaudible]
Professor Robert
Shiller: The price--I'm
going to come back to that.
The price of the option will
always be above that line,
so there's no arbi--there are
possible--it depends on if the
price is wrong--they're
arbitraged.
Let me come back to that.
This is a put option.
This is intrinsic value for a
put option because it's the
opposite of a call.
If the strike price is $20 and
the stock price is selling for
$15, then you can see that it's
in the money because you can
make $5 by exercising.
You have the right to sell it
for 20 but you can buy it in the
market for 15,
so you buy it for 15 and sell
it for 20;
you make $5.
On the other hand,
up here--if the stock price is
$30, you have the right to sell
it for $20.
Well, that's worth nothing;
I can sell it for 30 in the
market.
Then what--let me jump to this;
this isn't exactly the order
that I wanted to do it,
but the--this has to do with
arbitrage as you were saying.
The price in the market should
always be greater than the
intrinsic value,
until the exercise date--the
last date for an American--even
American or European,
but let's talk American.
This pink line is my price for
the option;
we'll talk about how we get
that line from theory,
but price--if the--let's say,
if it's an American option it's
got time to go.
Let's say the exercise date is
not for another year and it's
out of the money;
the price of a share is only
$15 but the exercise price is
$20.
That option is still worth
something today,
right?
It's not worthless.
It would be worthless if you
exercised it today,
but hey, you're not going to
exercise it today.
The reason it has value is that
the price might rise above $20
sometime over the next year and
so it--you have a chance of
making money on it.
That means the price of the
option is always going to be
worth more than the price of the
stock.
No, it's always going to be
worth more than the intrinsic
value.
What about at the money?
An at-the-money option--if the
price of a share is 20 and the
option--and the exercise is 20,
exercise it today and it's
worthless.
It has to be valuable because
fifty-fifty chance the stock
price is going to go up and so
you have a good chance of making
money on it.
So, it's going to be worth a
lot more than this one was down
here because we're at the money.
Any little jostle upward is
going to put it in the money.
There's a big chance that this
will become in the money,
so it has real value;
whereas, down here,
the option doesn't have much
value because it would take a
big price move to put it in the
money.
Then what about up here?
Even when they're in the money
they're worth more than
intrinsic value.
You kind of wonder,
well why would that be?
Well, it's because this thing
is better than owning the stock.
Let's say, at this point,
when the stock price is 25,
I'd rather own the option than
to own a share minus $20 because
the option can't fail me as much
as the share can.
The share minus $20 could be
negative in value before the
exercise date,
but the worst that can happen
to my option is it would be
worth nothing.
The arbitrage,
Peter, that you were referring
to is the arbitrage--what if the
price were below this line?
Maybe that's what you were
thinking.
What if the option price--what
if the stock price is $30 and
the option is selling at $5?
If it's an American option I
have an immediate arbitrage.
I buy--if it's a call option I
would buy the option for $5.
I would exercise it and sell
for $30 and I'll make money
instantly.
That can't happen.
We can't have the option price
selling for less than intrinsic
value, so you know just from
arbitrage that that pink line is
always above the solid line.
Moreover, there's another
arbitrage relation which I
didn't show on the chart,
but if we draw a 45º
line here from the origin,
that's plotting the stock price
against the stock price;
it has a slope of one and it
comes out of the origin.
No option can be worth--can be
priced up above that 45º
line--above here.
In other words,
an option can never sell for
more than the stock.
Does that sound obvious?
Why would you pay--if the share
is selling for $25,
why would I pay $30 for the
right to buy at that $20?
Obviously it's ridiculous;
the stock itself is an option
to buy the share at a $0
exercise price,
so it has to be worse to have a
positive exercise price.
Now, I wanted to stress the
put-call parity relation and
this is another arbitrage thing.
The put option
price--arbitrage--the absence of
arbitrage opportunities implies
that the put option price minus
the call option price equals the
present value of the strike
price--that's discounting it
from this exercise date to the
present--plus the present value
of any dividends coming between
today and the exercise date,
minus the price of the stock.
This has to hold because if it
didn't hold, there would be an
arbitrage opportunity.
The put--let me just show you
why.
This diagram is supposed to
explain that.
I've got here the intrinsic
value of the call,
which is the yellow line,
and this is an intrinsic value
of a put.
We've got them both at the same
exercise price.
Then, I've shown here the stock
price on the blue line;
stock price against stock price
is just a 45º
line--a line with a slope of
one.
Well, you notice that if I were
to buy a call and write a
put--that's the same thing as
shorting a put--I would have a
combined portfolio with just
those two.
I would have the yellow line
here and I'd have minus the pink
line here.
I would have a parallel
straight line that looks just
like the stock price just
shifted down.
If I buy a call and short a
put--or write a put--it's the
same thing as owning the stock
minus the exercise price.
So, that's what we have in the
put-call parity relation,
so that we're taking account of
dividends.
That diagram didn't show the
fact that stocks will pay--might
pay dividends between now and
the exercise date.
You can see what I was just
saying.
I've got--I said call minus put.
Well, this is put minus call,
minus the price of stock.
I have a minus sign in front of
everything here,
but it's just what that diagram
shows.
What put-call parity means is
that we only need a theory of
either call prices or put prices
and then the other one falls
right out of put-call parity.
All I need is a theory of call
prices, so we will just forget
about puts and we'll just talk
about calls from now on.
If I give you a problem to ask
you--what is the put price--what
is the price of a put?
You would go in and calculate
the price of a call and then
calculate the put option price.
We'll put this on right hand of
the equation.
The put price would equal the
call price plus the present
value of the strike price,
plus the present value of
dividends, minus the price of
the stock;
so, that makes it very easy.
All we have to do is worry
about calls.
Where am I?
The question for financial
theory is, what determines this
pink line?
You agree that it should be
above intrinsic value.
As the option gets closer to
expiration--as time moves on and
the exercise date is getting
closer and closer in time,
this pink line is going to go
down, down, down.
On the last day,
it hits the intrinsic value.
What is it before the exercise
date?
I'm going to start with a
theory, which illustrates how we
calculate these things.
This is a theory that applies
to--so that we can understand it
easily--that applies to a
strip-down situation.
I'm going to derive the price
of an option under the
assumption that it's very
simple.
There's only one period between
now and exercise;
it's a European option.
We're going to exercise it in
one--we have an exercise date of
one period and also under the
restrictive assumption--and this
is for pedagogical purposes just
to simplify option theory--that
the stock price,
S, is the stock price
today.
The stock--this stock is very
special because next period it
can have only two values.
It's S times u if
the stock goes up;
u stands for up.
It's S times d if
the stock price goes down.
What I'm saying--what's
arbitrary here is,
I'm saying that there are only
two possible prices for the
stock next period--Su or
Sd.
That's not real world because
as you know there are all kinds
of infinite number of possible
prices next period.
Again, this is just--I think
that we should be able to figure
out what the price of a call
option on this stock should be
worth.
It's very simple.
They say it's very simple,
but the people who invented
this won the Nobel Prize for
this,
so I won't--I don't want to
make it--this wasn't so simple
in the history of financial
thinking.
Do you understand the situation
that we're proposing in?
It's just like--there's this
very funny stock that we
know--for some reason we know
that S is the price today
and next period,
when the option exercise date
is, its price is either going to
be Su or it's going to
be--S times u--or
it's going to be S times
d.
Then, there's an interest rate
and we can both borrow and lend
at this riskless interest rate.
What should the option be worth?
In this case,
I'm going to call C the
current price of the call today.
Now, this is before the
exercise date,
so the price of the call is
going to be worth more than the
intrinsic value.
I'm going to call
C_u the value
of the call next period if the
price is up and
C_d the value
of the call next period if the
price is down.
That's the thing that we read
off of those broken straight
lines.
So, C_u would
be the stock price minus--it's
the stock minus the exercise
price if it's in the money.
We know that in advance because
we already know what the two
possible prices are next period;
so, we already know what the
two possible option values are
next period.
This is the intrinsic value if
it's up and this is the
intrinsic value if it's down.
We'll call E the strike
price of the exercise price of
the option.
Is everything clear here?
It's just such a very simple
world.
I'm just saying there are only
two possibilities;
it's a very simple world and
there's only period between now
and exercise,
so it's very simple.
Now, what I'm going to
say--we're going to develop an
arbitrage theory of options and
we're going to say that you want
to--you'll take any profit
opportunity that's riskless.
It ought to be possible to get
a riskless profit opportunity
here by investing both in the
stock and the option because
there are only two possible
values for the stock and you've
got both a stock and an option.
There must be a riskless
portfolio because the price of
the option depends only on the
price of the stock on the
exercise date.
What I'm going to do is get an
optimal hedge ratio,
H, that makes my
portfolio.
I'm going to form a portfolio
of the stock and the option and
I'm going to put them together
so that I have a riskless
portfolio;
that's what I'm going to do.
Out of that is going to fall a
value for the price of the
option.
This is what you want to do.
We're looking for a riskless
profit opportunity.
Let's consider this,
we're going to write one call
and buy H shares and I'm
going to pick H so that I
have no risk at all.
It's easy to see how you do
that because we already
know--before the exercise
date--we know that if the price
goes up it will be worth
uHS--my portfolio--if I
have H shares,
the H shares will be
worth uHS.
uS is the price;
H shares will be worth
uHS.
I've written one call so this
would be worth uHS minus
the price of a call.
Similarly, if the price
stock--if the stock price goes
down, then this is the
value--intrinsic value of the
call,
then next period on the
exercise date the portfolio will
be worth dHS minus
C_D.
Let's choose H so that
the two are the same.
All I have to do is set this
equal to this and solve for
H and that gives me the
optimal hedge ratio.
So, H is equal to
C_u –
C_d,
all over (u –
d) x S.
Now it's very simple to get to
option pricing.
If I can form this portfolio
where I have [short]
one call and [long]
H shares in a portfolio,
it's a riskless portfolio,
so it has to earn the riskless
rate of interest.
That's what no arbitrage
assures.
It can't be possible to get a
riskless portfolio that earns
either more or less than the
riskless rate because if that
did happen I would have a
riskless opportunity--ability to
earn more than the riskless rate
with no risk.
That's contrary to arbitrage.
The return on--since you
invested HS - C in the
portfolio, the return on it--the
total value of it--has to equal
(one plus the riskless rate)
times (HS –
C).
If you substitute in for HS
– C,
you find out that it equals
this.
Substitute for H into
this and you get the price of
the call today.
It's simple algebra,
but there it is.
So, that's the arbitrage theory
call option price.
That might be less than
intuitive to you.
See, that was very simple
arguing that got us there.
We merely said,
the way to think about options
is that options move with the
stock price and they're
perfectly correlated with the
stock price over this interval
because if the stock price goes
up you know you've got
C_u.
If the stock price goes down,
you know you've got
C_d.
So, you have only one source of
uncertainty but you have two
assets, so you can put them
together to eliminate risk.
If you put them together that
way they have to earn the
riskless rate and you just solve
for it and you get this value
for the call option.
This is the inherent insight
that Black and Scholes came up
with in their classic 1973 paper
on option pricing,
which I've come to,
but this has to be the price of
the call option in this simple
world;
otherwise, there would be
arbitrage.
The interesting thing about
this is that there are no
probabilities in this formula.
What's in this formula?
I've got the riskless rate;
I've got intrinsic value;
I've got the difference between
the price and the two
circumstances,
but nothing to do with
probabilities.
This puzzled people.
People thought,
well doesn't the price of an
option have to depend on the
probability that it will come in
the money?
If it's an out of the money
option, don't I weigh the
probability?
It's not in this formula.
You might say,
it's implicitly in the formula
because the relationship of
S to Su and
Sd involves
probabilities,
but it's not in this formula.
Black and Scholes,
in their famous paper,
used this kind of reasoning to
get to the standard option
contract, which--option formula.
I'm not going to derive it
because the mathematics is quite
a bit more difficult,
but it's exactly the same logic
that I just went through with
the binomial option pricing
formula.
This is one of the most famous
formulas in all of finance.
What Black-Scholes did is,
under certain assumptions about
the stochastic properties of
stock prices and under the
assumption of no arbitrage
opportunity,
they came up with a formula
that an option price should
follow if there's no arbitrage.
I'm just going to present their
formula and then we'll think
more about options.
The Black-Scholes formula--call
T the time to exercise.
Before, I just said it
was--when we talked binomial,
I just had--I said it was one
period hence,
but now we're allowing the
exercise date to be any distance
in the future.
So, T is the time to the
exercise date.
This is for our European
option, although it's often used
to apply to American options as
well.
We'll call σ^(2) the
variance of the one-period price
change.
N(x) is the cumulative
normal distribution function,
which you can find on Excel;
it's called normdist,
so I don't want to get into
these details.
This is the formula that
Black-Scholes won the Nobel
Prize for.
Well actually,
Black died at a relatively
early age from throat cancer;
he was a heavy smoker and
people don't do that anymore,
so that's one risk that is
over.
Scholes won the Nobel Prize for
this--they don't award that
posthumously--for this little
formula.
It says, the price of a call is
equal to the stock price times
N(d_1) minus
the exercise price times
N(d_2),
where d_1 is
given by this expression and
d_2 is given by
this expression.
That might not be intuitive to
you.
We could spend a couple of
lectures making that more
intuitive, but I'm just going to
stop with that formula now.
That's the formula that I used
back here to make this pink
line.
I just--I had to plug in a
value for σ^(2) and
T, but I did that and I
used the Black-Scholes formula.
The Black-Scholes formula does
what we sort of think it should.
The price of an option should
be greater than the intrinsic
value everywhere,
but here is the exact equation.
This is one of the most famous
equations in finance.
It might even be on your--if
you have a financial calculator
you might have a key that you
can press.
It's already on your laptop and
you don't even know it
probably--maybe--depending on
what kind of programs you have.
It's easy to compute in Excel;
you just have to use this
normdist.
This cumulative normal
distribution function is not
something you can do by hand;
you have to use a--it would
involve an integral that doesn't
have an analytic solution,
but you can get it on Excel.
Now, the critical problem with
the Black-Scholes formula,
however, is getting some of
these parameters that have to go
into it and the tough one is
σ^(2);
most of the other things we
know.
If you're trying to actually
price an option using
Black-Scholes,
S, we already know
that's just the stock price.
E is the exercise price;
we know that--that's written in
the option contract.
T is the time to
expiration date;
we know that--that's written in
the contract.
r is the riskless
interest rate;
well, that's easy to
tell--that's just quoted in the
market.
There's only one thing that
remains that's tough and that's
σ^(2).
That's the variance of the
stock price.
Black-Scholes says you have to
know how variable the stock
price is to price an option and
intuitively you can see it.
Isn't it obvious that the more
variable the stock price the
more valuable the option is?
If the variance were zero,
then the option would just be
the intrinsic value because
there's no chance for the stock
to do anything unexpected.
If it's out of the money and
the variance is zero,
the option is worthless.
If it's in the money and the
variance is zero,
then it's worth something,
but it's only worth the
intrinsic value.
If σ^(2) is 0,
the price can't move anywhere,
so there's no problem.
As σ^(2) increases,
the option gets more and more
valuable;
if it's out of the money it's
getting more and more chance to
come into the money and so
that's in the formula.
The key variable in the
Black-Scholes formula is the
variance of option--of the
underlying stock price;
that's the kicker;
that's the hard part.
People who trade options use
the Black-Scholes formula,
but there's a problem and the
problem is you've got to plug in
a number for σ^(2).
So, what number should I plug
in?
Well, you might say,
let's take historical numbers.
I know pretty much what the
variance of stock price changes
is;
let's use the historical
variance.
I wanted to show you the
historical variance of stock
prices.
I have--since I like history,
I go all the way back to 1871.
What I did to compute this
chart is I took the S&P
composite or S&P 500 Index
back to 1871.
This is my spreadsheet,
which is on the web under our
classroom materials.
I took a six-month moving
average of six-month
changes--six-month standard
deviation of the percentage
price change for every month
from 1871, July,
to April of 2008.
The important thing to
understand here is that the
variance is not constant through
time;
it moves around.
There are high variance periods
for stock prices and low
variance periods.
I like to look at this picture
because it's interesting.
The first thing that is
interesting is that,
overall, the market has been
remarkably consistent for over a
hundred years.
The variance back in the
nineteenth century doesn't look
any different;
nothing has changed in a
hundred and thirty years;
the market has always been
volatile.
There's only one thing that
jumps out at you when you look
at this picture and that's these
numbers in here.
You notice those numbers in the
middle?
That was the Great Depression
of the 1930s and something went
really haywire in the financial
markets in the Depression.
This is 1929;
it wasn't so much 1929,
but remember this is a
six-month--it's a lagging six
months.
So, where does it--maybe the
1929 crash is here somewhere.
I'm not sure exactly where it
is, but something went really
haywire after 1929 and the
markets got extraordinarily
volatile for a while.
That was a crisis period in
American history that shows up
really well on this picture,
but since then nothing much has
happened.
It's interesting to look
recently.
This doesn't look very
important;
it shows how important our
lifetimes in the broad sweep of
history, but your lifetimes are
from in this region right here.
The thing that's interesting is
that we have been recently in a
very low volatility period for
the stock market.
This is around 2003.
We were in a high volatility
period in the 1990s--nothing
like in the Great Depression,
but high in the '90s and then
volatility just collapsed and
the markets were the deadest and
dullest place to be in the
world--the stock market.
Partly, I think this is because
our--we were--who knows why this
was.
I'm going to throw out a wild
suggestion.
It's because we were distracted
by the housing bubble and all
talk after the stock market
peaked in 2000.
Lots of people just lost
interest in the market and all
of their speculative enthusiasm
was focused on housing and the
stock market was kind of
forgotten.
There has to be at least an
element of truth to that story,
but something has been
happening lately.
Look how much volatility is
shooting up now;
this is because of the world
financial crisis that we're in.
If you look at this picture it
doesn't look like the world
financial crisis is very
important compared to historical
events so far that we've seen in
the past.
Now, I want to define what we
call implied volatility.
What the--you can do with the
Black-Scholes formula is it
requires that you input
σ^(2) to calculate what the
price of an option should be.
Why don't we take what the
price of the option is and work
backwards to figure out what
volatility is implied by the
price.
Do you see what I'm saying?
You can solve--you can turn the
Black-Scholes--the Black-Scholes
formula gives the price of the
option in terms of σ^(2).
Well, I can turn it around
because I know what the market
price of the option is;
they're traded on the CBOE.
So, I would take the market
price of an option and turn it
around and get what the implied
volatility is from
Black-Scholes.
The CBOE does this for you
because they trade S&P 500
options and they have it on
their website and its called
VIX, so I have VIX there.
That's their volatility index.
The CBOE was created in 1973.
Unfortunately,
the series doesn't--it goes
only back to 1986,
but it's been going for a long
time.
You can't get implied
volatility back to 1871
because--although there were
options traded back then,
there was no organized market.
You can't get a consistent
series of prices of options
going that far back,
so you can't get implied
volatility.
Maybe you could do it if you
got some records from some
broker and find some option,
but it would be hard.
Our implied volatility only
goes back a little over twenty
years, but the interesting thing
is I have plotted here both the
implied volatility over that
period and the actual
volatility.
You see that they line up
fairly well, but this shows the
strength of the Black-Scholes
formula.
Black-Scholes does seem to be
pricing options well enough
because the implied volatility,
while it's not perfectly
exactly equal to the actual
volatility, it's close and so we
can see that the formula makes
some sense.
I just wanted to conclude this
lecture by talking about the
effort we've made to get
single-family home price options
going at the Chicago Mercantile
Exchange.
As I told you,
I and some of my colleagues
have been campaigning with
futures exchanges to create
futures markets for home prices
and,
ultimately, for commercial real
estate prices and other economic
variables.
We went to--we started
campaigning almost twenty years
ago, but recently we have been
talking with the Chicago
Mercantile Exchange and they
created futures markets for
single-family homes in May of
2006 using the S&P
Case-Shiller Indexes.
That was our objective,
but when we went there the CME
said, well why don't we start
options as well--options on
futures.
So, we have a futures contract
and they launched options on
home prices.
You can see all these things on
the Chicago Mercantile Exchange
website.
What we have now are both puts
and calls for ten U.S.
cities.
Unfortunately,
they're not doing well;
they're not selling well,
but they're still going and
we're hoping that we can get
them to connect.
Often markets are slow at
first, so I hope that that's the
story--that it's just a slow
beginning.
Let me say what we have;
maybe it's a good down to earth
way to illustrate the value of
options.
I was telling you how to price
options, but I didn't tell why
would you buy one.
Well, I did tell a story at the
beginning.
I talked about an investor
wanting to invest money in
options and a writer hoping that
the option will expire
unexercised and hoping to make
money.
I didn't really go behind that
and emphasize why you would do
that.
I think the example of a home
price option is very easy to
see.
Let's consider a situation that
someone--I don't think any of
you are homeowners here at this
point;
maybe some of you are--probably
not.
But imagine--try to imagine
that you bought a house a couple
years ago and now the housing
market is collapsing.
You bought that house probably
on a mortgage,
so you borrowed 80 to 90% or
maybe even more of the money to
buy the house.
Now, the home is falling and
you're thinking,
hey wait a minute.
This house is worth less than
my debt and you start to get
upset.
You're thinking,
well you know I'd like to move
to another city,
but then you realize,
I can't do it.
If I sell my house,
I won't be able to pay off the
mortgage;
I'll be bankrupt before I--I
can't move.
This is very real.
In fact, economy.com,
a consulting firm,
estimates that in the United
States today 10% of all homes
are underwater in that sense.
The mortgage debt is greater
than the value of the home and
that number is increasing
everyday as home prices continue
to fall.
Some people are very upset.
So, what can they do?
Well, one thing they can do or
they could have done a couple of
years ago if they had thought to
do it,
they could buy a put on the
home--on homes in the city where
they have a house.
I put in, say,
around--let's say I put in
$500,000 into a house and I'm
worried that its price might
fall.
Well, if you buy a house and
you buy a put on that house
together, the two together
eliminate your risk.
Let's think of it as just
buying a put on a house rather
than on an index.
I buy the house for $500,000;
I put up $400,000 and so--I put
up $100,000;
the mortgage puts up $400,000.
I'm underwater if the house
drops $100,000.
I've lost--my mortgage debt
exceeds my--I don't want that to
happen, so why don't I just buy
a put on the house,
which is a right to sell the
house at $400,000 until some
exercise date;
then, I can't possibly be
underwater.
If I ever decide to move or if
it's an American option,
I can just--if the price of my
house is less than $400,000,
I'll just exercise my put.
There's no way for me to get
wiped out.
In fact, I could buy a put at
$450,000 and that way I would
always be sure that I'd have
$50,000 left.
So, that's the idea of using
options as a hedging mechanism.
While I gave an example in
terms of real estate and it's
not widely used that way,
this same idea is used a lot by
investors in other domains,
so I think options have a very
real risk management purpose.
In a sense, an insurance
contract is like a put option.
If I buy fire insurance on my
house, then it's like buying a
put option on my house,
but it's only exercisable if
there's a fire.
What it says is,
if my house burns down,
the put option--I can sell
whatever remains at a price,
which is determined by the
insurance contract;
it's the same as a put option.
Insurance is not fundamentally
different from finance.
We've had a little trouble
deciding whether we want home
equity insurance or just
puts--home equity puts--so we've
created the puts.
At some point,
we want to also create
insurance on homes,
someday;
I hope that happens.
There is no home equity
insurance.
These are just different
incarnations of the same risk
management ideas.
The fundamental idea here in
finance is that you can
create--options are examples of
derivatives;
I should add that a derivative
is a financial contract that
derives from another financial.
So, an option is a derivative
because the price of the option
in the options market depends on
the price of something else in
another market--the stock
market.
So, our real estate options are
another example of derivative.
The price of the put option
depends on--in the option
market--depends on the price of
the house in the housing market.
One of the themes in my
forthcoming book,
which I'm writing right now,
is that derivatives are like
insurance.
They're fundamentally important
to risk management vehicles and
they could have helped prevent
the subprime crisis that we're
now in if they had just gotten
established and more developed.